attention is the most precious resource
that we can leverage to actually get
things done increase productivity and
achieve highest performance in whatever
we do
focus is not something we have it's a
skill we gain by training our brain
our brain is finely attuned to
distraction so today's digital
environment makes it especially hard to
focus
thanks to a variety of sources of
entertainment news socialization and
more work it is easy to get distracted
not only do distractions slow us down
they can cause serious errors
to prevent this we should develop better
mental focus
research has shown that individuals who
can sustain their attention for long
periods of time performed better on all
sorts of cognitive challenges than those
who cannot
i guess we can all agree that no matter
what goals profession or work you are
currently pursuing a disciplined mind is
critical for your success
so how can we train our brain to stay
focused
the brain is the most complex biological
structure in the human body
around 100 billion neurons are
communicating via 1 million billion
connections that are sending signals up
to 1 000 times each second which is one
quadrillion events every second of your
waking life
the brain can be divided into sections
with different roles from breathing and
heart rate to coordinating movement and
involuntary reflexes
the most developed parts the neocortex
hold memories our abilities to plan
think and imagine hope and
dream the brain's building blocks are
not exactly simple either
neurons are not just wires they alter
and process information
synapses where signals are handed over
form one neuron to the next contain
receptors for hundreds of chemical
signals opening them up to outside
influence
given how complex our brain is can we
actually train it to become more focused
there is plenty of research showing that
it is possible
first stop multitasking
multitaskers might seem superhuman but
they pay a big price according to a
stanford study
in a sample of 100 stanford students
about half identified themselves as
media multitaskers the other half did
not
the test examined students attention
spans memory capacity and ability to
switch from one task to the next and the
multi-taskers performed more poorly on
each test
multitasking reduces our cognitive
abilities due to the fact that the brain
can only fully focus on one task at a
time
to stop multitasking make a list each
day of what you need to accomplish and
then choose one task at a time
if the other things on your list come to
mind while you are working on a chosen
task just remind yourself that they are
already on your list so they will get
taken care of
if you think of new things that you need
to do just jot them down on your list
and then go back to your current task
give your full attention to the task at
hand to improve the quality and speed of
work
second treat your mind like a muscle
everyone knows that when you lift
weights your muscles get bigger and you
get stronger
however when you stop exercising muscles
shrink and you get weaker
new research shows that the brain is
more like a muscle it changes and gets
stronger when you use it
training your brain to stay focused is a
matter of practice
every time you experience distracting
thoughts you have to acknowledge them
for what they are time and attention
killers
whenever you feel like you must stop
working you should push it a little
further
if you have big trouble focusing right
now you shouldn't try to work for 60
minutes straight
build your levels of focus gradually
first two weeks try focusing for 20
minutes take a five minute break then go
again
in two months you should be able to stay
focused for 60 minutes and get a lot of
things done
third find your peak hours
by studying thousands of people
researchers found that we are truly
focused for an average of only six hours
per week
this means that you want to be really
diligent with what you put into those
hours
some people perform better during the
day while others do great during the
night
to find your most productive hours or
the peak hours you should actively
measure your productivity during various
hours of the day
pay attention to your energy thought
patterns distractions motivation and
moods while experimenting different work
hours
then allocate your toughest tasks for
those moments
make sure you allow at least a week to
establish these peak hours
so if you try to get your most important
tasks done from 8 am to 10 am experiment
it for a week
next week focus your attention on
critical tasks starting from 10 am and
ending at 12 pm
over time this will help you identify
your best performing hours
fourth
avoid distractions you can't train your
brain to stay focused unless you ensure
that your external environment also
lacks distractions
while it may sound obvious people often
underestimate just how many distractions
prevent them from concentrating on the
task at hand
your phone for example should never
disturb your attention
turn off the notifications say no
whenever someone interrupts you and be
committed to cut off every possible
distraction around you
minimizing the sources of distraction
isn't always as easy as it sounds
while it might be relatively simple to
turn off your mobile television or radio
you might find it much more challenging
to deal with an interrupting co-worker
spouse child or roommate
one way to deal with this is to set
aside a specific time and place and
request to be left alone for that period
of time
another alternative is to seek out a con
location where you know you will be able
to work undisturbed
fifth maintain realistic to-do lists
in an effort to complete as much as
possible every day we are tempted to
fill our daily to-do lists with a wide
variety of tasks and no breaks in
between
while we may be able to perform most of
the activities in such a list the ones
occurring in the latter part are bound
to suffer
this is because we are already fatigued
by the time that we get to them
as such be realistic about your to-do
lists and include only the kind of
activities which you were sure that you
can do with the resources at hand
moreover include breaks in between these
tasks
they give you a chance to relax at
specific times of your day
this is known as the pom doro technique
of time management
according to management experts this
technique allows you to rejuvenate
yourself and refresh your brain in
between tasks
as a result your focus is laser sharp
once you resume your work
as such be realistic about your working
capacity and take breaks throughout your
day
sixth take a short break
have you ever tried to focus on the same
thing for a long period of time
after a while your focus starts to break
down and it becomes more and more
difficult to devote your mental
resources to the task
not only that but your performance
ultimately suffers as a result
traditional explanations in psychology
have suggested that this is due to
attentional resources being depleted but
some researchers believe that it has
more to do with the brain's tendency to
ignore sources of constant stimulation
researchers have found that even taking
very brief breaks by shifting your
attention elsewhere can dramatically
improve your focus
so the next time you are working on a
prolonged task be sure to give yourself
an occasional mental break
shift your attention to something
unrelated to the task at hand even if it
is only for a few moments
these short moments of respite might
mean that you are able to keep your
mental focus sharp and your performance
high when you really need it
seventh
create daily habits and routines
developing new habits and routines might
also help improve your ability to focus
a routine works to train your brain for
the activities that will follow
it conditions your brain to expect the
work that you have in store
by following a routine you are able to
perform the same activity right before
you begin working
as such this activity in your routine
acts as a warm-up for your brain
it can be as simple as making a cup of
coffee or as vigorous as a session of
exercise
intentionally repeat the good behavior
at least 30 times
researchers believe that humans need to
have a repetitive event at least 30
times before it becomes a new normal
our brains recognize routines and
proceed to create the neural pathways
that are necessary to complete the tasks
signified by the routines
as such to boost your ability to focus
create new habits and routines
your brain will adapt and condition
itself for the tasks within your day
hate
practice mindfulness
practicing mindfulness is another way to
help increase one's focus
in one study researchers analyzed a
group of hr professionals
the managers had to engage in
simulations of the sort of complex
multitasking they engaged in each day at
work
these tasks had to be completed in 20
minutes and included answering phones
scheduling meetings and writing memos
with information pouring in from
multiple sources including by phone
calls emails and text messages
some of the participants received eight
weeks of training in the use of
mindfulness meditation and the results
found that only those who had received
this training showed improvement in
concentration and focus
members of the meditation group were
able to stay on task longer switched
between tasks less frequently and
performed the work more efficiently than
the other groups of participants
practicing mindfulness can involve
learning how to meditate but it can also
be as simple as trying a quick and easy
deep breathing exercise
ninth improve sleep
numerous studies have shown that proper
sleep helps improve concentration and
focus
when we are well rested we can pay
better attention to new information that
we come across in our daily experiences
besides sleep helps make new information
stick
during sleep the brain replays memories
from the day making the neural
connections stronger
this helps us remember the things we
experienced when we were awake
different stages of sleep play a role in
forming different types of memory such
as learning how to do something like
playing a piano compared to learning
facts
sleep also helps our creativity helping
us find new solutions to problems by
looking at things in a new way while we
sleep you may have heard people say they
will sleep on it in order to solve a
problem or make a decision
therefore it is important to try and get
as close to the recommended amount of
sleep as possible on most nights
for most adults it is seven to eight
hours of sleep per night
tenth
make time for exercise
physical exercises like running swimming
and weightlifting aren't just good for
the body they promote brain health too
numerous studies have shown that
physical exercise is closely related to
the cognitive function through a cascade
of cellular and molecular processes that
promote angiogenesis neurogenesis and
synaptogenesis thus enhancing learning
memory and brain plasticity
scientists think regular exercise may
help stimulate the release of a chemical
called brain derived neurotrophic factor
which some research suggests helps
rewire memory circuits to improve their
functioning
therefore if you want to train your
brain to stay focused and productive
make sure to exercise on a regular basis
if you found this video useful i would
appreciate it if you smash the like
button
also make sure to subscribe to the
coding tech channel and click on the
notification bell
enjoy the rest of your day